So, you've built some agents and they're
working. Actually, they may be working
really well, doing amazing things. And
now you want to put these agents into a
production setting. What are the other
things you have to worry about? For
example, do your agents need some form
of human approval during their
processing steps? Will your agents be
running for long periods of time in the
presence of failure? How do you address
these issues? Today, we're going to be
learning about a new mechanism that
addresses both these issues, and I'm
really excited to talk about it. So,
let's get
started. Hi, I'm Greg Benson. I'm a
professor of computer science at the
University of San Francisco and I'm
chief scientist at Snaplogic. And today
I'm excited to talk about a new
mechanism that we've developed at
Snaplogic called agent continuations.
Agent continuations allow you to capture
the full state of complex agents that
can be used both to do arbitrary human
and loop processing and also be the
basis for reliable agent continuation
through taking snapshots. This work came
out of the agent creator research group
at Snaplogic. First, let's talk about
the general challenges that we face with
agents today. First of all, there's a
lot of concern about where the human
sits relative to agent processing. That
is for people to get comfortable with
agent automation. Key aspects of agent
execution require some amount of human
oversight. And so there's been lots of
work and lots of techniques for
including human in the loop. I'm not
going to go over all of those, but
essentially the agent will get to a
point where there's a designated tool or
task that might be a high value or high
risk task like transferring a lot of
money or deleting an account. And we
need a way to ensure that when the agent
gets to that point that in some manner
it gets to the human, the human can
provide the final determination or
decision. Another problem with agents is
that many of them will be long running.
Um there's lots of steps in agentic
processing and the longer that any
process runs, the greater chance that
there may be a failure. And we'd like
some way to not lose all the work that
an agent has done and be able to
potentially uh checkpoint our agent
state to be able to resume from a point
that is not the beginning. And finally,
uh, increasingly agents are going to be
operating in a distributed environment
and not just on your desktop, for
example. And so what are the
considerations for running agents in a
scalable distributed environment? Let's
talk about basic agent execution just so
we can level set for the rest of the
talk today.
An agent is essentially a loop that
involves calls to an LLM that specify
potential tools for that LLM to use. And
if the LLM determines that it needs to
use those tools, it will come back to
the agent loop, which will then call the
tools on behalf of the LLM request and
collect the tool results and send them
back to the LLM. And it does this in a
progressive loop. LM tool call LLM tool
call and so on. Now, it's also possible
that a tool can be an agent itself and
that's illustrated in the picture here.
We have a sub agent. So, this is the
basic agent processing setup. Pretty
standard across agent frameworks today.
Clearly, there's a lot more going on.
There's a lot of interaction and this
gives us a detailed view of the
interactions I just mentioned. The mo
main point of this is to to indicate
that even simple agents have quite a bit
of interaction with the LLM and with the
tools. So what are some of the agent
execution scenarios that we're concerned
with addressing? I've mentioned tool
calls that require human approval. This
is a common idiom that is uh a tool call
is an access to something in the
environment. something that may require
uh human approval for the access itself
or it may be an action in the
environment like like a deleting
account, transferring money, um doing
something of consequence. And in those
situations, it's desirable to allow the
human an opportunity to approve that
request. Another situation that can
happen, it happens to me all the time
with coding assistants is the landscape
of LLM and the LM APIs is changing
rapidly and their use is is dynamic
and often new models come out, they get
used heavily and you might encounter
rate limiting and there's other reasons
you might encounter rate limiting. uh
but there are different ways to handle
this situation and we should seek
mechanisms in the presence of this and
finally I mentioned longrunning agents
uh especially agents that have to do
very complicated tasks or extensive
research to to multiple systems either
external to your organization or
internal to your organization. um the
longer that the agent runs, the more
susceptible it is to some potential
failure, either some sort of network
failure or hardware failure. Um and as
these sophisticated agents run longer,
we would like a way to not lose all of
the work that the agent has done. So, so
we want to also tolerate failures in the
presence of longunning agents.
Another thing I want to elaborate on
is the fact that in increasingly agents
are becoming more sophisticated in the
sense that not only will you have say a
single level agent that has its access
to an LLM and its tool calls but you may
have an agent configuration in which you
have a main agent or an orchestrator
agent and then several sub aents. In
fact, those sub aents could have their
own sub aents. This is this pattern is
is becoming quite common. So then the
question is in the presence of these
more sophisticated multi-level agents,
how are we going to deal with those two
primary
uh primary tasks that I mentioned
earlier, human approval and state saving
in the presence of failure. The last
concept I want to talk about is what I'm
calling agent loop persistence. And this
is the idea of if you have an agent
running, there is this loop. That code
that actually is doing the loop has to
run somewhere. It has to be on a
physical machine running. It might be in
the cloud. It might be in your desktop.
It it could be in in many locations.
That agent loop is going to be
interacting with the user in some
manner. Maybe you're doing it from the
command line. Maybe you have a web app.
Um maybe it's interacting through some
sort of third-party communication
channel like Slack.
Most of the frameworks today to support
things like human loop require that that
agent loop be running continuously. Even
if it's waiting for something like
waiting for a human response from Slack,
it requires they require this this agent
loop to to persist. And this is
something that we wanted to address in
our agent continuations work. That is we
wanted to develop a mechanism that would
would allow us
to fully shut down the agent loop or
multiple agent loops in some cases and
then restart them at a later point say
when the human has provided their
approval. So what are agent
continuations? So first off agent
continuations are inspired from the
programming language theory concept of
continuations. This is a long-standing
concept in programming languages in
which you can at any point in time
during program execution you can say hey
I want to stop the program execution at
this particular point and sort of bundle
that up so that I could resume or
continue the execution from that point
going forward at some later time. In
effect what that lets you do is it lets
you
take a snapshot of the program's
execution so far so that later it could
be
continued. Um it's a powerful mechanism
that doesn't exist in in all programming
languages um because it requires fairly
sophisticated runtime support.
But this mechanism, this
language continuations mechanism was the
inspiration for what we're calling agent
continuations in which we want to do the
same thing. We want to be able to say at
some point during agent execution, which
again might be through multiple tool
calls, multiple LLM calls, and maybe
even calls to sub agents and their tool
calls and LLM calls. At any point in
time, we want to be able to say, "Let me
pause what the agent is doing. Let me be
able to save that state and then return
it back say to the application layer so
it can for example process a human
approval or perhaps persist the state of
the agent at that moment in time to be
resumed later. So now let's go into the
details of agent continuations. First
let's make some observations about why
this may even be possible. The way we
work with LLMs in agents today is we
maintain the messages array. The
messages array is really almost a log of
all the interactions that you've had
with the agent or with the LLMs. The and
if you if you look at it right, it
records a history which is actually
replayed back to the LLM to make its
next inference. And so in a sense,
uh, agent interactions with LLMs are
already doing a lot of the bookkeeping
to keep track of everything that's been
done so far so that that past history
can be sent back to the LLM for the next
action, say for the next tool call
response or the next decision that the
LLM has made. So, one of our one of the
key insights is that we're building on
top of this aura this messages array
which already is saving quite a bit of
the state of the agent. Now, it's not
quite enough, but it's pretty close.
Before we get into the details of how
agent continuations are implemented,
let's look at how you use the prototype
framework.
First, I'm going to show you how to use
the
framework like other agent frameworks
that is without continuation support.
And this should look pretty
familiar. We have tools and we use a
decorator to indicate that these Python
functions are
tools. Uh and then when we go to create
the agent, right, we just send the tool
list to the agent. So the agent knows to
use those tools in processing a user
request. Now, one thing I'm not showing
you here for brevity is you can also
include instructions or a system prompt
to the agent. Now once you've
instantiated your agent then you can
make a request and give a user prompt
and the agent will go off and do its LLM
request and its tool calling and
eventually come back with a response.
Let's look at our continuation extension
to this standard approach. There's only
a couple of differences. So now let's
look at using the framework with
continuation support. And you'll notice
there's only a couple of differences.
Let me point those
out. First off,
now with continuations, we can designate
a tool as needing approval. So here
we've said that this tool will need
approval. In addition, instead
of creating an agent from the agent
class, we're going to use the
continuation agent class. And other than
that, it's pretty identical to the
standard agent usage. Now, in terms of
execution, it's a little bit
different. The
response may be the complete response of
the agent if the agent was able to
complete its task. But if the agent for
some reason needs to
suspend, then the response will be a
continuation object.
This continuation continuation object
has metadata that can be inspected so
that you can understand the reason for
suspension. In this example here, we're
assuming that because we know we built
the agent with the tool call that needed
approval that that continuation object
is going to need a human approval
response which could be true or false
depending on what the human ultimately
decides. But let's say in this case that
we decide to approve this tool call
request. So we update the continuation
object appropriately with the positive
human approval. And then you can send
the continuation back to the agent using
the same request method. And the agent
will know because this is a continuation
object that it needs to resume from the
place that it suspended in the first
place. that is in this case just before
the tool call so that we can get the
human
approval then
the agent can continue and get the final
final response. So let's go into a
little more detail about the
implementation.
So with continuations the forward
processing of the agent remains the
same. you're going to do LLM calls. The
LLMs are going to come back with a tool
call request. We'll pull perform the
tool work call request as long as they
don't necessarily need is human
approval. Uh but if the human approval
isn't needed, it's standard agent
processing. If we get to a point where
we determine that we need to suspend
like for human approval or if we've
reached some other suspension condition,
that's when we create the continuation
object. The continuation object embeds
the standard messages array with some
additional metadata. That metadata
provides the continuation enough
information of how to resume when we
want to send the continuation back to
the agent. Ultimately this continuation
object will be sent back to the top
level agent which we do some
final processing of to
make the application layer to make it
easier for the application layer to
understand why the continuation was
suspended and also to allow it to
provide human approval updates if
required.
So essentially what we do is we take
this fairly potentially complicated
nested continuation object and extract
the core information that the
application layer needs to act on to
make it easy for that application layer
to make those approvals. Then once the
application layer has updated the
continuation object, we send it back to
the agent. the agent knows that it's a
continuation and has the logic in order
to reconstruct the agent back to its
state so that we can continue the
execution. Now, one really important
point of all this is
that once you've suspended the agent and
you've created the continuation object,
you actually don't need to keep any of
the agent loops running in your system.
that is they can be shut down because
we've captured enough information to
restart everything back to where it was.
And this is a really powerful aspect of
agent continuation. So going into a
little bit of the detail just to get a
sense of what this continuation object
actually looks
like. I've sh I'm showing two versions.
First is a single level continuation.
Uh you can see that we've wrapped it. We
have the top level continuation, the
messages array which is the normal
messages array and the two other pieces
of metadata are this resume request
which indicates exactly which tool call
for example we need to resume at and
also processed is going to be populated
with whether we approved or say
disapproved in the case of human
approval and I mentioned that before the
continuation is returned learned is that
we extract to the top level of this
object the metadata that allows the
application layer to easily update the
continuation
um so that it can proceed after we send
it back to the agent. On the right, a
slightly more complicated continuation
object in which we have an agent that
calls a sub agent. And the main point
here is that our format is recursive and
it can handle arbitrary layers of
nesting. And you can see that here in
the fact that we have a resume request
that now has its own continuations
object with its own messages. And that's
the messages of the sub agent and its
own resume request and processed. So
let's look at a full example. Here we
have a multi-level HR agent and so the
top level agent has an email tool and it
has access to a sub agent the account
agent tool which is responsible for
creating account and setting account
privileges. I have a abbreviated system
prompt up here and we construct our
continuation agent for the HR agent
here. Now let's take a look at the
account agent for a moment. It's its own
agent with its own tools. Create account
and authorize account. In this case
here, authorize account needs approval.
But you can see it uses the same basic
setup. Uh we give it its system prompt
up here and its tools. And this sub aent
is going to be used by the top level HR
agent. Here I have an example prompt to
create a new account and that prompt
will be sent to the agent to be
processed. Now in this example here,
it's set up right such that eventually
the account agent sub agent will need
human approval for the authorize account
tool which will cause the agent to
suspend create a continuation return
that back to the application layer for
processing. Here is an
illustrated diagram of the steps that I
mentioned. In this diagram, we have the
application layer that's interacting
with the user. We have our HR agent and
it's tool call send mail and then it's
using the account agent as a tool. And
that account agent has its create
account tool and its authorized account
tool. Now in the scenario I just
described, we'll get down to the point
where we know we need approval for
authorized account. So that's the point
at which we need to suspend and start
creating or building up our continuation
object. And that's what happens here. So
the approval propagates a continuation
object object that gets expanded at each
level as it's propagating back to the
application layer until finally we have
the full continuation object for the
application to inspect and then act on.
Now once the application layer has done
that then that continuation object can
be sent back into the HR agent and the
framework will know that we need to
restore the agent state and the sub aent
state back to where it was when we
needed the approval in the first
place and that will be handled all by
the framework. So let's do a quick
demo. So let's look at our
prompt. So, we have the prompt here as a
JSON.
And I'm going
to
run this
prompt
here. So, I'm just giving that prompt as
the first prompt to the agent starting
off. And I'm going to send this out
to a response file. And the whole point
of this is to show that these things are
fully decoupled and that these objects
contain all of the state that we need.
So let's look at
the response
object and this has the things that you
can imagine. There's the continuation,
there's the top level messages and if
you go down right here is the sub aent
messages with its system
prompt. And finally, if we go down to
the bottom of this object, this is that
top
level approval object that the
application layer can then present to
the user and then update. So here I'm
just doing it manually. Obviously you
would do this in application code. So
I'm going to save that. And now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to send that
edited
response back to the agent. And the
point of this is that now the agent will
reconstruct its state but with the
information that the tool has been
approved so that the agent can continue
processing. And there we go. If you look
here right we agent has indicated that
the account has been successfully
created uh and that a security level has
been granted and that we now have the
end reason of completed. The other thing
I'll note in this output here is
that everything above now is normal a
normal messages array. That is uh
there's no sign of continuation in the
final result
object. The continuation is just
introduced when we need to
suspend. Okay. So let me go over just a
few details.
Um, our prototype is built up on top of
the OpenAI Python API. There's no other
dependencies. We have the prototype
implementation. Here's the link that you
go to on GitHub and it should be in the
channel notes as well. Where do we want
to take this? We've already implemented
a version with more general agent
suspension that is beyond just human
approval. is that setting up arbitrary
suspension points like after a certain
amount of time, a certain number of
turns, even asynchronous requests for
suspension. And what we're looking at is
not just not necessarily developing uh
this prototype into a full separate
agent framework um because there's lots
of good frameworks out there, but rather
looking at ways to extend existing
frameworks, something like strands or
pyantic AI. Now I should also mention
that um we're not the first framework to
consider state management. Some of the
other frameworks do have forms of state
management. However, uh the in
our investigation of the state
management, they either sort of lack the
human approval element or the um the
sophistication of having arbitrary
depths of nesting into sub aents. And so
we think our
approach is novel in the sense that it
combines both those both a human
approval mechanism and also this
arbitrary nesting uh of complex agent.
This work came out of the agent creator
team at Snaplogic. Agent creator is
Snaplogic's visual agent building
interface and platform. Not only did we
build that out in Python, but we built
it out in agent creator itself. And you
can see here that we allow our users to
create sophisticated agents using a more
visual approach. And you can also
visualize in the platform agent
execution. We prototyped continuations
in the Snaplogic agent creator
environment as well. Uh so we we did it
both at the Python layer and we also did
it at our higher level uh layer in in
the Snaplogic platform. In conclusion,
agent continuations are a new mechanism
for managing agent state and human in
the loop processing. We have a prototype
implementation that you can access on
GitHub from the link on this page. And
if you want to learn more about building
agents visually with SnapLogic Agent
Creator, go to agentcreator.com.
[Music]